this last week was a really big one
giving it kicked off with the
PlayStation experience and the game
awards last weekend but here's five of
the biggest things that came up
uncharted 4 had everybody impressed and
by everybody i mean me when drake's hair
and clothes got wet during the
PlayStation experience gameplay demo but
it seems that was even more to be
excited about Naughty Dog held a panel
at PlayStation experience where a bunch
of artists presented images and
graphical demos showing the graphical
upgrades to the sequel which have been
possible thanks to the power of the ps4
Nathan Drake is noticeably older and
more realistic looking you can check out
the panel as well as Drake's vascular
arms and insanely detailed profile on
gamespot street fighter 5 was announced
for ps4 and PC and everybody went crazy
mostly because it's not coming to Xbox
as for the good news the game will
feature cross-platform multiplayer
between ps4 and PC the game which is
traditionally appeared on multiple
platforms is now console exclusive to
Sony due to a deal where the game will
be produced in partnership with Sony's
while Sonia followed up this news by
saying they feel the game's natural home
is on PlayStation Microsoft have pledged
to make amends for the game missing on
their platform
in disappointing news The Witcher 3 has
been pushed back another three months
from its original delay to Maine 19 up
next year it turns out the ambitious RPG
is proving to be an awful lot of work
and CD Projekt RED have said they must
rather use all this extra time to
produce a polished game than a flawed
one while a bunch of other developers
and publishers have opted to release
broken games this year CD Projekt RED
has said we know what to do we just have
to do it we don't want to release the
game with bugs that undermine the
gameplay another story that exploded
with opinions this week was the news
that rise of the Tomb Raider is going to
be published by Microsoft we already
knew the game was set to be exclusive to
Xbox one but Microsoft's role as
publisher brings into question how and
if the game will be ported to other
systems square enix released a statement
on the news which reads Microsoft is
always seeing huge potential in Tomb
Raider and they will get behind this
game with more support across
development marketing and retail than
ever before which we believe will be a
step in continuing to build the tomb
raider franchise as one of the biggest
in gaining in years of super people who
are stupid or perhaps as rich people who
are rich somebody bought a defective
amiibo for $25,000 a manufacturing issue
has spawned a whole batch of amiibos
that just don't look quite right and
while most of us would just opt to buy
the notch broken one apparently paying
$13 for the busted version could have
earned you twenty four thousand nine
hundred and eighty seven bucks in profit
that mass took me longer than I'd like
to admit anyway the factory sealed
legless peach amiibo in question was
sold on eBay as a piece of junk and
bought as a collectible I guess it's
like they say one man stupid broken
amiibo it's another man well it's still
just a stupid broken amiibo ask you a
question of the day let me know what was
the most you've ever paid for cool
gamers and
what it was this week on site I cover up
on games that feel like movies on the
gist Lucy gives you everything you need
to know about the order and we start
rolling out our game of the year awards
check out through one hour mobile
reissue and 3ds categories right now on
gamespot that is it from me this week
thanks for sticking around as always
have yourself a wonderful weekend and
i'll catch you again on monday